Sal: So what I want to do today,
since this is conference
on entrepreneurship,
I thought I would give a
little bit of a background
on the story of Kahn Academy started.
I think some of you all
might be reasonably familiar.
Actually, before I even
start, how many of you all
have been to the site or
watched a Kahn Academy video,
oh, very good. I think we have a very high
penetration in our demographic.
I think it'll be
interesting because I think
the story of Kahn Academy,
more than almost more than
entrepreneurial stories is kind of a,
I don't want to say accidental,
I want to think that
some of it was somewhat by design,
but it has been this kind of
organic process and it's
still not 100% clear
where all this is going to
lead to, although it seems
like it could lead to
something pretty exciting.
We could rewind back to
2004 and I was an analyst
at a hedge fund in Boston.
My aunt and uncle and
their children, my cousins,
were visiting me from New Orleans.
It was right after my wedding.
I got married in New Jersey,
went back to Boston, and
they were visiting me and the
oldest of the children,
Nadia, she was 12 years old.
It was 4th of July weekend in Boston,
I don't know if any of you
all have been to Boston,
they have a nice 4th
of July fireworks thing
over the Charles River, and
I distinctly remember while
we were waiting for
the fireworks to start,
I was just killing time by
giving my family brain teasers,
the kind of brain teasers, a
good interview question at Google
or whatever, and I don't
know if you all have ever
done this with your family,
but some people say,
"I don't care, I don't want
to think right now," but
I distinctly remember Nadia,
she was 12 years old and
she was like, "Don't tell me the answer.
I can figure it out. Can
they see each other ... ?"
At 12 years old, she was
tackling these brain teasers
as well as any 25 year old
computer science gravita
that I'd ever interviewed before.
I remember the next day, we
were touring the colleges
and we went to MIT and I
remember telling Nadia,
"I'm pretty impressed
by how well you tackled
a lot of those brain teasers yesterday.
You should think about MIT."
I remember right when I
said that, my aunt gave a
a little look to my uncle,
and I wasn't sure what that
look was about, maybe
it was something else,
completely unrelated,
but I remember that look.
The very next morning, my
aunt and other auntie told me,
"Sal, thank you so much
for believing in Nadia.
It really means a lot.
You're like a big brother to
my children and a role
model, but I thought I would
let you know that Nadia's
actually having trouble in Math.
She's gotten great grades,
she's a straight A student,
but she just took a placement
exam and she did not
place into the standard track
where you take Algebra in
8th grade and so on and so
forth, she got placed into
a slower track.
I said, "That's impossible.
She was tackling stuff way more
abstract and deep and
thought-provoking two nights ago
than anything that you
could imagine covering in a
6th or 7th grade Math class."
So when Nadia woke up, I
said, "Nadia, I have trouble
believing this, what
do you not understand?
Why do you think you didn't
do well in the placement exam?
It was unit stuff, converting
kilograms to grams and
all the rest." I said, "Nadia,
I'm 100% you can tackle that,
so what do you say when
you go back to New Orleans
and I stay in Boston, after
my work and after your school,
I tutor you? We do
something over speakerphone,
We'll figure out a way to be
able to see what each other,
what we're writing all that that."
We started using Yahoo Doodle
and we started doing this.
It was kind of fun for me
... Even while I was at the
hedge fund, when anyone
works at a hedge fund, you
kind of have a rationale
for why you're doing it,
(audience laughter)
although I do have an argument on how
it actually does contribute to society,
but that would take me
longer than this talk.
But I used to tell my friends,
"I want to do this job
long enough so that I could
save enough money that I could
start a school on my own terms."
That was always something
that was a little bit
in the back of my mind, I
didn't really have a sense of
what that would mean, but it
was like a life ambition for me.
So it was fun for me to
tutor my cousin because
could start to warm up and
help my cousins in the process.
The first month was difficult.
I remember with Nadia
it was like, "x plus 3 is
equal to 10. What is x?"
Her answers were always
like, "7?" or I'd say,
"If you have 2 kilometers,
how many meters?"
She'd say, "2,000?" and I
was like, "Are you sure?"
It was this thing, she was
a smart girl, but she just
had no confidence.
Anything outside of Math,
her brain was engaged, as
soon as she got a formal
Math problem, it's like
she didn't want to think.
There's a couple of things
that I had done early on and
I don't talk a lot about this
because the videos are what
Khan Academy got most known
for, is I want to make
something for Nadia so that
I can make sure she has
100% proficiency of the core
stuff, so that she doesn't
answer every question
with another question.
So I wrote this little thing,
this little Java Script
question generator for her
that will only give her
as many units, problems as
necessary until she should
get 10 in a row or as many
basic Algebra or exponents,
any of these core skills.
The next day on our tutoring
session I would say,
"Did you do the problems?"
She'd say, "Oh yeah, I did them,"
and I didn't really believe her,
so I put a database behind
it so I could keep track of
when she did the problems,
how much time was it
taking her and all the rest,
very simple stuff at this point.
Then I started making
one module after another.
This was literally a
dedicated software effort for
one 12 year old at the time.
She eventually did progress
through the tutoring and
the software which, the videos
aren't even on the radar
at this point.
Then I started to tutor
her younger brothers,
more and more family
members, it was kind of this
fun thing ... Sometimes when
I'd call up a distant relative,
I was like, "Can I tutor your
kids?" they thought that there
was some type of strange catch to it.
They're like, "Sal must not be doing
well in this hedge fund thing."
Fast forward now to 2006,
I have this cohort of
20 or 30 kids around the country
that different times though,
I still had a day job and I
would come home and I would
try to tutor them all
and do these sessions.
I would try to do these
conference calls with more than
one student, that got tricky.
I vented at a dinner party and
one of my buddies, [Zooly] says,
"Why don't you just record some
of your lectures on YouTube?"
I said, "No, not YouTube.
That's for dogs on skateboards.
That's not for serious mathematics."
Then I went home and once
I got over the idea that
it wasn't my idea, I
decided to give it a shot.
I put those first YouTube
videos up there; I think it was
"Greatest Common Divisor"
or "Least Common Multiple"
and I started doing a bunch
of them, 20 or 30, the same
stuff that I was covering
with my cousins at the time,
and a couple of things happened;
I joke about this a lot,
but it's absolutely true, the
first feedback I got from my
cousins was that they
liked me better on YouTube
than in person. (laughter)
I'm hoping it's only an
education tutorial context,
but it actually makes a lot
of sense; they could pause,
they could repeat ... There's
a lot to be said about
human interaction, there's
human mentorship and
think they value that.
They value the fact that their
cousin, who was in Boston,
who had a job, who was
married, took the time out
of his day to care about their lives.
That definitely was a positive for them,
but I could tell just from
my interactions that the
actual tutoring sessions
was super stressful.
No one wants to say that
they don't understand.
No one wants their cousin to feel like,
"Maybe Nadia isn't worth the time," or
"Maybe she's wasting my
time," so all of a sudden
they could do it in a
destressed environment.
When we had our live sessions,
it was just really for questions.
The other thing that
happened is I started getting
letters from people. I just
randomly put it on YouTube
I remember that first time
YouTube says do you want to
make these private or public? I was like,
"I don't care, Public," and
other people started to watch.
At first I was suspicious
because I told four cousins
to watch the video and six
people would watch it, like,
"Who are these two people
that are watching my videos?"
I don't know if you ever saw
"Julia and Julia" where she
wrote a blog and she keeps
refreshing it to see if
people are watching, that was me in 2006.
All of a sudden, it became
clear that definitely people
who I wasn't related to
were watching the videos
and then they started to comment,
they started to say, "Thank
you," which that by itself
is huge because I don't
know if you've seem most of
the comments on YouTube,
(audience laughter)
they're not all G-rated.
Frankly, I think if I was a
physical teacher, just to get a
thank you from a student
every now and then,
that's a pretty powerful idea,
but I would start getting
these thank yous, but then
the comments would be like,
"I was going to flunk Algebra
and now I'm the top student
in Algebra because I
watched those four videos."
I was like, "My God, I was
sleeping or taking a nap or
shaving or something and this
person was able to learn Algebra.
That's a pretty profound idea!
You can imagine, I just got
excited and I just kept going.
When I started off, I
didn't think this was ...
There was something in my head that said,
"This is a neat idea. I
can make that video on
Least Common Multiple once
and it's there forever.
My cousins can use it and
even if no one else uses it,
it's kind of a nice little
thing for the family.
Maybe my grandkids
could eventually use it,
or my great-great grandkids.
It would kind of be like
this neat thing and maybe
... maybe in the future,
other people might actually
want it, so I just kept going.
Actually I was building out
the software at the same time.
The software's funny because I
made up all of these modules,
and as you can tell, a lot of
this has come out of being lazy.
I got tired of assigning
the modules to my cousins.
Before I was like, "Okay
Nadia, now you've gotten
ten in a row on this, you're
now ready for this module.
Now that you've gotten ten in
a row for negative numbers,
you're now ready for fractions."
That got tiring for me, so I set them up
in this kind of graph
structure, so it would
automatically assign them.
Once you got ten in a row on this,
you're now ready for these modules.
Once you get ten in a row on those,
you're now ready for those modules.
I said, "Look, this is kind
of a neat graph structure."
I had it visually displayed for myself
so I could keep track
of all these modules,
so let me have my cousins look at them.
Once again, they liked that.
They could see where they were going and
what they needed to do to understand
to eventually get to Trigonometry or
eventually get to Geometry, or whatever.
I had that out there and this is probably
thing not to do if you're trying to ...
And I wasn't trying to start a business or
a not-for-profit at this point,
but that software alone
got so popular by 2007
that it was taking down my
$50 a month web hosting.
My brilliant entrepreneurial mind said,
"Oh, then I'll just turn it off (laughs)
instead of paying $100 a month."
That happened, the video
traffic kept growing;
hundreds, thousands, ten thousands,
until you fast forward to 2008 ...
And then something
interesting, even across,
some interesting things started to happen.
I started getting letters from teachers.
Once again, this is just for my cousins,
you know, whatever ... But
teachers started saying,
"You already gave the
lecture on adding fractions.
I don't have to give the lecture anymore.
Now I'm assigning these
for my students and then
I use my class time, the
teacher's class time,
to actually interact with my
students, to actually kind of
flip the classrooms so now students can do
homework while they're in the room and
get the lecture at home
at their own pace,"
and get all of the benefits
that my cousins had,
the reason why they
liked them to begin with.
So you fast forward to
2009 and this whole thing
just kind of got too exciting.
I had trouble focusing on generating Alpha
in my day job and this
is probably the fourth
iteration where I was
tempted to quit my job.
The previous three, we kind
of looked at our finances
and said, "No, we can't,"
but by the fourth,
we're like, "You know,
it wouldn't be completely
ridiculous to try this out for a year."
My rationale was at
this point, I was like,
"There is something here,"
because at this point,
I was getting hundreds of letters a day.
These were not letters of someone saying,
"This was nice to have."
"This helped me review for an exam."
Some of these letters were like,
"This is the reason why I
could go to college," or
"This is the only reason why I'm able to
pass class X, Y or Z."
It sounds like there's something here,
I made the decision to
make it a not-for-profit,
just because really, I
wanted as many people
as possible to use it, so I was thinking
there's so much worry
about education right now,
let me just keep doing it.
I took the most naive approach to
starting a not-for-profit or
really starting a business,
I just kept making videos and hoping
someone would notice.
In 2009 I did that, you fast forward ...
Luckily by May, June,
July, August of 2009,
people began to notice.
Google brought me in, they said,
"A lot of our engineers,
a lot of our people here
like to use your videos with their kids.
Would you be willing to talk to us?"
I go to Google and
halfway into the meeting,
they're like, "So what would
you do with $2 million?"
I said, "Is this in an
education context or
just a broader question for
what I would do ..." (laughter)
Very different answers!
But it was clear it was about education.
I said, "You know, I
would ... well, beyond
giving myself a salary, I would build out
that software platform that I started off
for my cousin so that students can all
work at their own pace,
so that teachers can
get data and analytics
on what the students
are up to, so that we
could take this model
that these teachers had already started
experimenting with, this model
of flipping the classroom
and kind of supercharging
it with a software.
If you have the software,
now whether you're
at home or you're at
school, every kid could work
at their own pace. In the same classroom,
you could have kids doing 5th grade Math
and kids doing Trigonometry.
The teacher's role will
now not be to grade papers,
not to be a lecturer, but to spend
every moment of their time
interacting with students,
and having the students,
every moment of their time,
not sitting passively in
a room waiting for the
period to end, but to actually
interact with each other
and maybe tutor each other."
They liked the idea.
It looked like that funding
process was happening,
although that didn't
happen until later on.
This is a lesson I learned,
I only have one experience in this,
but it's like one of these things where
there's a period of time where you think,
"Boy, someone needs to notice this," and
you think you're doing
something that's pretty cool
and your customers or
your students or whatever,
it's like this is a life-changing thing,
and you're doing it, but
no one else is noticing.
At some point, nine months into it,
I was getting pretty insecure.
I was getting like, "I need
to start updating my resume."
I don't know if the hedge
fund will hire me back
because I've done this flaky
thing and all of this stuff,"
but then once all of a sudden it did hit,
it was kind of crazy
because it was literally
in the same ... Google looked
like that process was going,
Ann and John Doe, actually
they were the first
to say, "You at minimum deserve a salary."
In August of 2010, so this is very recent,
this is like last year, I
think it was July or August,
I get a text from Ann.
She was at the Aspen Institute saying,
"Bill Gates in front of 2,000 people
talking about you right now."
I said, "That prankster Ann!" (laughter)
or maybe that text was
sent to the wrong person
because it was a very surreal idea, but
later on, about two weeks later,
I got a call from Mr.
Gates' office saying,
"You may or may not
know, but Bill is a fan.
He uses these videos
himself and he uses them
with his kids," and immediately
when they said this,
I'm like, "I gotta review
some of those videos
and see what I said." (audience laughter)
But he said, "He would like to
meet if you have some time."
I was literally staring at a blank
calendar. (audience laughter)
I was like, "Oh yeah, I think I can move
a few things around." (audience laughter)
"We should be able to
figure out something."
We met and he asked how
we could support ...
I was like, "You know, it would be nice
to 'come out of the closet'," so to speak.
I was recording in the closet ...
And so he supported us,
we got office space,
we have a team, and
then Google came in and
now we're essentially a
team, we're eight people now,
we're based in downtown Mountain View and
we're building out this software platform
and videos, I keep
making videos to kind of
provide an education for anyone anywhere.
We started a pilot in Los Altos.
Once again, we didn't
think our strategy was
go into classrooms right from the get-go,
we were focused on the end student,
the millions of students
that are out there right now,
2 million students using it
on their own every month,
but Los Altos came to us and said,
"What would you do in a classroom if
you had carte blanche?"
We said, "Look, we're building this thing,
every kid work at their own pace."
We didn't think they'd be into it,
but the next day they said,
"Yeah, can we start in two weeks?"
So we have two 5th grade clases and
two 7th grade classes in Los Altos now.
It's been pretty tremendous.
I think all of the
indicators, we could talk
maybe more about that later,
have been very positive.
Just to give a little bit of a clue of
the power of this is,
very recently a reporter
came to one of the classrooms to just do
a story on us, and she saw a 5th grader in
one of those classrooms
doing Trigonometry.
Just sitting there doing
Trigonometry problems,
you know, very casually and
the reporter's very impressed.
She sits down next to
the 5th grader and says,
"So do you think this is 5th grade Math?"
The little girl had a
very mischievous look
on her face and she goes,
"No, I think it's 6th grade."
(audience laughter)
So now going forward, I think
our strategy is two things;
and our strategy, frankly,
changes every week,
but the strategy is two things;
build out our software platform,
we're actually translating
it to ten languages
so it can reach more than just
the English speakers of the world,
build out the software
platform, so right now,
the exercises go deep, they go into ...
You saw in the video, they
go into Vector Calculus
and Biology and college
Chemistry and History
and all the rest, but have
the exercise platform,
first go through K through Calculus,
and then beyond that, college-level Math
and Chemistry, Biology,
Physics, all the rest ...
And build out what we're
doing in these schools.
Over the next year,
we're going to to about
10 to 15 schools and school districts to
kind of expand this Los Altos idea and
see how we can really transform what
happens in the classroom.
That's kind of an update
on what we're up to.
I think now we can, I believe
there's just going to be
a Q and A part of this.
(audience applause)
Male voiceover: [unintelligible]
For those of you living in the Bay Area,
the person who's going
to have a chat with Sal
needs no introduction;
three-time Emmy Award Winning Raj Mathai,
who just three months ago was named
News Anchor for NBC Bay Area.
He was a very well-regarded sportscaster
for a number of years with that station.
So let me welcome to
the stage, Raj Mathai.
(audience applause)
Raj: Hello everyone.
Should we sit ...
Sal: Yeah, yeah, yeah ...
Raj: First of all, is
he a stand-up comedian
or an educator? This is phenomenal.
That was wonderful.
Sal: By virtue of my name, I
feel the desire to entertain.
(laughter) But I will keep my shirt on.
(laughter)
Raj: I'm glad you brought it up because
the first thing this morning,
I'm putting on my suit,
getting ready to come
here and my wife says,
"What's happening today?"
I said, "I'm going to the TiEcon event
and I'm going to spend
part of the afternoon
with Salman Kahn," and
she dropped to the floor.
(audience laughter)
Raced to the closet,
"What am I gonna wear?"
"You're coming with me?"
I said, "No, the real Salman Kahn."
You have more of an impact I think, than
the other one, right?
(laughs) (audience applause)
Sal: If you want a really surreal story,
apparently Bill Gates did
a search for Salman Kahn
(audience laughter)
and he forwarded his entire organization
the other guy saying,
"Did you know there's
another Salman Kahn?"
Just the idea of seeing Bill Gates look at
Salman Kahn without his
shirt on was a very ...
(audience laughter)
Diffident ... Anyway, it's not about him.
Raj: I think like so many people,
like everyone here in the audience, I too,
just backstage, just
captivated about your story.
This isn't the first time that I've heard
about your story, I've been following you
for a while now.
So what happens now?
Here we are, we have a
lot of entrepreneurs,
we have a lot of venture capitalists,
and one of the big questions is,
"Okay, this is great, it
seems very successful,
but it's not-for-profit."
So at what point ...
Sal: What is is for, then? (laughs)
Raj: At what point do you turn the corner,
if that point is even on your radar?
Sal: No, we're definitely
not going to turn,
this isn't like a batch and switch,
we're not going to be
not-for-profit at some point.
I think I would have to do something
pretty shady at this point to actually
turn it into a for-profit.
This simple answer is we're going to
stay as not-for-profit.
The decision early on was, and
I think a lot of you all can,
I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with for-profit,
I obviously worked for
in a very for-profit
industry before this,
it's pretty much about
that's all it was for
... (audience laughter)
Raj: That's the next session at 2:00.
Sal: Yeah, exactly,
(laughter) stock tips ...
Early on, it was in 2008 actually,
some VCs had approached
me and it was actually
pretty exciting; conversation number one,
because they said, "This is
awesome. We can fund this.
You'll be able to get a salary.
You can keep doing these videos full time.
You don't have to find all
the spare time to do it.
It'll be a double bottom line business or
we can, a social venture,
whatever you want to call it,
and if it works out, you'll be rich."
That didn't sound bad to me, so
we scheduled another meeting.
It was obvious by Meeting Two,
there was something that just wasn't ...
I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with this,
but I was just enjoying this so much.
It was really why I kind
of woke up in the morning.
By Meeting Two, the
conversation started to
become like, "You should
continue doing this,
but we should focus more on test prep,
and maybe we could charge for this or
have a subscription model or a freemium,
or whatever you want to call it,
I'm not saying that
they were wrong or bad,
but I just started, it didn't feel as fun
all of a sudden, so I was just like,
"Hold on, maybe we'll just wait on this
and see where it goes."
Then you fast forward a little bit more
all the way to 2009 and
I talked to a few other
VCs and I just went through kind of an
introspective process because
like I said in the talk,
one of the really fun things about this
was the idea that people
were saying "thank you,"
that my great grandkids could use this,
that kids all over the world could this
really for all time, that
even if I got hit by a bus,
these things could keep teaching.
I went through the thought experiment of,
"What's a home run in either situation?"
A home run in the for-profit world,
which isn't a bad thing,
it's by no means certain,
is you become this major player, IPO,
or you get acquired and I would feel
pretty good about that,
I would have created
a big business that I'm sure would have
reached many people, I
would become rich which
wouldn't have been bad, but then when you
think about the total amount
of the not-for-profit side,
it was even a little more exciting.
There's kind of this
opportunity here, maybe ...
to start an institution,
to start something that
could last maybe hundreds of years.
This is what I told my wife,
"There are no for-profit
entities that last
more than, very few last
more than a century,
but there are not-profit
entities that do."
Not to put Kahn Academy
in the same league as
these organizations,
but would I rather start
a GE or would I rather start a Stanford?
When I thought about it
that way, I was like,
"It would kind of be more exciting just
to start the latter," so
that's the not-profit ...
Raj: It's interesting,
your background (applause).
It's interesting you bring up Stanford,
even your own CV, MIT and then to Harvard,
you are talking about real
traditional institutions here.
What you're doing, in
many ways can be viewed as
very untraditional,
higher educated people.
Is there a negative side of this?
Have you gotten some pushback whether it's
from the traditional education community
or anyone else in the community?
Sal: Right now, and luckily, I expected
a lot more pushback,
especially when we go into
schools and all, but the fun thing is,
the core thing that we're doing,
we're going straight to the students,
or straight to the parents,
so we don't have to
get buy-in from a lot,
but even in the schools,
we're dealing with the schools that have
wanted to do it, we're not forcing anybody
to do anything, and I
think the only resistance
we get is sometimes when
people see just kind of
on the surface, they
say, "Oh wait, lectures
on video, they're going into classrooms,
wait ... this is here
to replace teachers."
or this going to somehow
mechanize the classroom.
What we're saying is the exact opposite.
These videos and the software, they're
actually about to
rehumanize the classroom.
Instead of having a teacher
up here giving a lecture
and students down there
passively listening,
we're offloading all
that with the technology
and now class time becomes interactive.
We can tutor each other, the
teacher's going to walk by,
every moment of their time is going to be
mentoring each other, there's data,
there's analytics so that any intervention
that the teacher does is very productive.
The teachers who've experienced it,
they told us this is
why they became teachers
in the first place.
I think the only resistance is just the
knee-jerk reaction, but when they actually
see what we're doing, we're actually
all about empowering teachers.
Raj: Do you think there
will be some resistance,
even more so, as Kahn
Academy gets more well-known?
Right now it's well-known,
but it's going to
get to that next level where people,
especially now, the economic
climate in this country,
where there's so many budget cuts,
there's so much bad blood
going back and forth,
do you expect some
resistance, because I'm sure
there will be at some
point around the corner?
Sal: Yeah, and we have to
be careful there because
obviously, education's a very
politically charged thing
and we're trying our best to
stay out of the arguments.
We think regardless of where
everything else settles,
we can be relevant.
Maybe it will develop,
but we haven't seen it
in a strong way just yet.
Raj: In terms of the subject matter now.
You're doing all these videos by yourself?
I'm a TV guy, I get a sore
throat by talking a lot.
When you plan on expanding,
are you just going to
start bringing in other
experts in various subjects?
Sal: Based on what our
focus is in the short term,
we don't view that as [gating] factor.
I keep making videos, this is fun for me
because there's some stuff I know and
there's some stuff I get to learn,
I get to keep teaching
it and all the rest.
Even just one guy can
do K through Calculus
plus Chemistry, Biology and Physics
on a course of about three man years,
so it is this very scaleable thing.
With that said, we are
starting to look for
other potential lecturers.
I'll even say [unintelligible],
we're translating into 10 languages;
Hindi, Bengali, we've already started on,
and we want to do other languages.
There's an opportunity;
one, to help redo the videos
in this language or even
teach in those languages.
One thing that we're
missing is basic literacy
videos, but like in the context of the
developing world, that's super important.
Yeah, we are looking to bring
other people in the fold.
One thing we're not looking to do is
we don't want to be this crowdsourced
hundreds of thousands of teachers where
the student watches one
video from one teacher
and then another video
from another teacher
and it's different quality, first of all,
that already exists.
YouTube has that to some degree,
there's other sites that do that,
and we think that our niche is
really a bond with the teacher.
It's crazy because it's technology, but
we think we can actually form
a bond with the students.
People, once they watch 10, 20, 30 videos
from the same teacher, they're willing to
invest their time and their
emotional energy into it.
Raj: You can obviously sell and teach this
product amazingly because
it's your product,
you have a dynamic personality,
obviously very intelligent.
How do you bring the next person in there
to do the ...
Sal: It's an open question,
we're kind of doing,
there's a guy who ...
Raj: Like American Idol casting? (laughs)
Sal: Thinking about
that, like teaching Idol,
there's a couple of people who've,
there's some guys who are video bloggers
who are pretty hilarious
and intellectual and stuff,
and they want to try it
out, so we'll see how
they do ... And there's
a guy from MIT who's
a computer science, he's been
teaching computer science.
I think he's got a lot of potential,
but we're not in a rush
to find these teachers
because we want to take our time and
find people who really
resonate with students.
Raj: Your biggest fear moving forward,
obviously there's been
a lot of success now,
but is there something
in the back of your mind
that you're curious
about, that maybe you're
a little fearful about as
you move forward with this?
Sal: Yeah, I think any
organization at our stage
you don't want to be a flash in the pan.
The ambition is to be something that lasts
a hundred years, we'll be sad
if we don't last three years.
Our main thing is, let's
just make sure that
we are continuing to drive value,
that we don't get caught
up in these other things,
The focus of me just going
on TV and talking about
educational forum and
becoming a policy person
or something like that.
I think where we are
right now, we're in this
kind of inflection where
I think our main goal
is to always just put the blinders on,
stay focused on really
what got us to this point,
which is really the end student,
and making sure that we
continue to add value
to that student and then the people who
want to empower them, their
parents and their teachers.
Raj: In the Bay Area here,
a lot of us familiar with
school districts that are as successful,
whether it's in east
Oakland or east Palo Alto,
are you trying to target specific types
of areas, demographically, perhaps?
Sal: Yeah, we are focused
mainly on the Bay Area.
We're looking all over the country and
actually the world, we're going to a few
international schools, but
what we're looking to do,
Los Altos is obviously
not a community in need,
(audience laughter)
but what was really good about Los Altos,
two of the 7th grade classes we did were
actually slower tracked
kids and they've actually
been doing tremendous, they've shown even
more profound results,
so even Los Altos isn't
all uniformly fluent and well-healed.
What we're looking to
do is, other use cases,
less well-healed neighborhoods,
charter schools, private
schools, public schools,
all of the above, but the
one theme that we do want
in all these schools
is that there's buy-in,
that it's not just the
mayor or the superintendent
who's forcing it down; that the mayor,
the superintendent, the
principal, the teachers
and the parents all really,
really, really want this.
About the flash in the pan,
I think our biggest risk is
some schools kind of
half-way implements it,
and then it's a disaster.
Then everyone points and
says, "Look, it doesn't work."
I think that would be a
disaster not just for us,
but I think for the whole
idea behind it which
I think has a lot of power.
Our goal over the next
10 to 15 school districts
is to just make sure
that their unambiguous
success is like Los Altos.
Raj: What about you for
the actual content of it?
I mean, like any teacher,
and you are a teacher,
you have to stay fresh and current and
even continue to learn
about your own topics.
How do you do that? Is
that part of your day?
Sal: Yeah, there's some stuff that I know
by virtue of my background,
but there's some stuff
like Organic Chemistry ... I took it and
I did all right in the
class, I took it in college,
but a lot of people are
asking for Organic Chemistry.
It's like one of these core classes.
Every pre-Med and a lot of
Science leaders take this.
There's actually no
Organic Chemistry videos
on the web, there aren't
even bad ones out there.
(laughter)
So I said, "I need to
learn Organic Chemistry."
But the one thing that I emphasize,
I don't want to teach something unless
I'm excited about it.
We've all experienced
a teacher at the front
of the classroom who's like,
"The next step in the process
is ..." and you're like,
"If he doesn't give a damn, why should I?"
(audience laughter)
So I won't do a video
unless I'm excited about it.
The first day of studying
Organic Chemistry,
I was not that excited about it.
Actually once I immersed myself and really
started thinking about
it and really started
drawing [unintelligible],
it started to get exciting.
I kind of immerse myself in
subjects that I don't know,
I'll call up buddies that I think might be
able to connect some dots for me and then
once I feel like I have
a holistic picture,
then I'll just start recording.
I force a smile on my face and I do it.
Hopefully it shows up in the videos.
Raj: Like so many people
here, we [unintelligible]
last night and talking
about just taking a risk,
going against the grain,
going against the analysts
that tell you one thing, you
obviously are doing that.
What's the spirit, I don't
know about push back,
but when you tell your Indian parents,
"I'm leaving the hedge fund, my MIT and
the Harvard education and I'm going to do
this thing on YouTube," [unintelligible],
"What are you doing?"
Sal: Oh yeah. It's funny because my wife,
she's finishing up her
fellowship at Stanford right now,
but when I first told
people, especially at
[unintelligible] parties that ...
"What do you do?"
"I make videos on YouTube." (laughter)
I've actually heard this,
when they hear I'm ...
I've heard them, "Well, at
least his wife is a doctor."
(laughter)
Raj: It's interesting, though, right?
Sal: Yeah, thank God my wife's a doctor,
but although a resident,
she wasn't making the ...
but anyway, the day after ...
My mother's very supportive of it now,
but the day after I officially quit,
and I actually did not consult my mother,
not like a good [unintelligible] son,
but my mother called my
wife and my mother-in-law,
"What? How did you let him do this?"
Everyone's really pumped about it now.
Raj: As you look around at this room now,
is there something, a message that you
would want to give to
people here as you see
what you're doing in moving forward?
Sal: Yeah, there's a broader message about
entrepreneurship and I think that,
and I have a kind of a singular story,
I think there's multiple ways obviously to
kind of start something, but
my story as you could tell,
was just me trying to reach a need and
it was exciting for me
when just when a handful of
my cousins were obviously
benefiting from it.
That was enough. I was happy
with just that small success.
It was worth my time to build it then.
I think the lesson is whatever you do,
hopefully there's some
small subset of people
who find it life-changing
for them, maybe ...
or in some way, very compelling.
If you have that, then
it makes it worthwhile
for you to do it.
Then you kind of don't care how long ...
There's a possibility
that in 2004 I'm going to
start this online video platform and I'm
going to get venture funding and all that,
and I maybe would have
written a business plan,
worked at it for six
months and if I didn't get
[unintelligible] I would give it up.
Because I had, I was happy
with the small successes,
I was able to pursue it for 5 years before
I quit my job and then even I was pumped
about pursuing it
afterwards, so it was one
of these things where it was one those
unkillable ventures.
I think that's one of those things that
made venture succeed.
There's a lot of things, a lot of ideas
that people have and
the ideas just kind of
go up and it pitters out and it dies and
eight years later, it
becomes very successful.
I think there's something to be said about
maybe designing something
so it has a staying power.
Raj: Before the call from Bill Gates,
before all the cliques when it was just
with your family, what kept
you motivated by doing this?
Because yes, you quit a job,
a good salaried job to do this.
Sal: That's why I did not quit,
so I am a practical person there.
It was worth my time to do it.
I was still spending
probably 15 hours a week
with a day job doing
this for my cousins ...
Raj: What was that leap of faith moment?
Was there a point when you
finally looked and said,
"You know what, I can do
this. I want to do this."
What was that leap of faith moment?
Sal: That became pretty
clear in 2007, 2008
when other people were watching it.
My cousins were, Nadia, not to show off,
but she ended up taking
Calculus her freshman
year in high school and we
went from being a slow ...
When you see that with just one student,
you're like, "This could
be transformational."
That by itself made it worthwhile.
You start getting letters from students.
Then really, I had to
wait until 2009 because
the success of the site
bounced off with our own
financial risk, that was
the point where it just
became hard for me to
focus on anything else.
Raj: When you talk
about these cousins now,
where are they and are they kind of your
role models here of ...
Sal: Yeah, I tell Nadia
on a regular basis,
"You better be successful because ..."
(audience laughter)
There's a lot riding on this."
She's now at Sarah
Lawrence and some of you,
the [unintelligible] parents might cringe,
but she's a writing major,
but she's also pre-Med.
(audience laughter)
Raj: Really?
Sal: She's a writing major by choice.
She's actually a Math rock star.
Raj: And pre-Med by heritage.
Sal: And pre-Med by heritage, exactly.
Raj: As we wrap it up
here, the next phone call
from Bill Gates or whoever it is,
when they ask you how you're doing,
have you gotten better
in these last few years?
Because I would imagine you
have, with your tutorials.
Do you look back on those
first tutorials, you're like,
"Oh Gosh, I'm much better now."
Sal: Some of the other
ones, like my cousins,
they're not going to pay me.
I literally answer a telemarketer call in
one of those earlier
videos, I don't edit it out.
I'm just like, "No, I
don't want Dish Network,"
and I hang up. (audience laughter)
You can edit that out,
I don't want to get ...
Now Bill Gates is watching these videos.
I feel like maybe I
should be a little nicer,
a little bit more thought out, but
I think one of the things that's captured
peoples' imagination early on is that
it does feel personal.
It does feel like there's
just this guy recording.
It doesn't feel like
this publishing company
is doing these computer graphics and doing
all these, "The next
step in photosynthesis is
when the ... " This feels like this very
organic thing and so I
think we want to make it
more nicer, easier to
watch, more polished,
but we don't want to make it too polished.
Raj: That's a very good point.
There's that fine line
now of bringing in the
TV camera, the earpieces,
the makeup, the so forth,
are you flirting with that line, yet?
Or is it still you kind
of want to stay ...
Sal: We always want to be organic,
a guy at his screen capture board, or gal,
explaining the concepts in real time,
not with a script.
We might experiment with other things on
the forefront, maybe
History or Literature,
but for the most part, it's
going to be the same thing.
Raj: Sal, pleasant to
spend some time with you
this afternoon, I think I
speak for the entire room.
Good luck, continued success.
(audience applause)